you have to be comfortable with
complexity if you're going to work in
africa
if you're serious about changing things
you first have to understand why they
are the way they are we love complexity
and we we enjoy taking complexity and
making it simple
think about how difficult it is to
change your own habits
now expand that to an entire continent
this is the challenge faced by african
e-commerce company jumia
how do you change hundreds of years of
established precedent in how people buy
and sell
in many ways they've cracked the code
and they've done it differently than you
might expect but if you ask them
they've barely scratched the surface
[Music]
welcome to britain growth from stanford
seed the show where africa and india's
intrepid entrepreneurs share their
trials and triumphs with insights from
stanford faculty and global experts on
how to tackle challenges and grow your
business
we've got a bit of a departure from our
usual today this is the edited version
of a live event with accomplished
businesswoman juliette onoma juliet is
the chairwoman of judea nigeria
and chief sustainability officer of the
jamia group we spoke to her as part of
the stanford entrepreneurial thought
leaders series which as you'll hear
included real-time questions submitted
by viewers
together we explored what jamia has done
to convince africans to adopt e-commerce
how they're revolutionizing in formal
markets
and how much more there still is to
accomplish
[Music]
i wanted to start by getting to know
jamia and the problems it's trying to
solve
jumia is um an e-commerce platform the
largest e-commerce platform in africa
and we started in 2012.
and we started with a mission very
simple mission that we could
improve lives with the power of the
internet on on the continent we are
based in about 11 countries
and the 11 countries where we're based
and actually cover 70 of africa's gdp
and about 500 over 500 million internet
users
so the question is like you said what's
the problem we're trying to solve
if you're a seller in africa many years
ago
you only had two options on how you're
going to retail your products to
consumers either you had
to pay a very expensive high street real
estate prices for a modern retail shop
or you had no other alternative but to
operate in the open market very informal
open market is hot it has no amenities
or utilities and it's overcrowded those
were the only options you had especially
if you were a small medium enterprise
just uh trying to get by
so jimiya solves that problem for
a host of millions of smes and sellers
and merchants on the continent because
you don't have to register on jr
platform
you don't have upfront capital
expenditure in terms of putting up
retail space uh literally minutes once
you're registered and gone through the
training for selling online on junior
you can start your business so that's a
huge part of the problem the second part
of the problem of course was a logistics
problem so the first one was a
distribution problem
and even just staying on the
distribution one if you were a consumer
by the time you finally buy the products
chances are that the markups from the
very long distribution chain from
manufacturer to bulk breaker to
wholesaler and finally to retailer and
the neighborhood shop where you buy the
item you could be paying significantly
more than you should as as a consumer so
one was a distribution problem
from the consumer's perspective and from
a seller's perspective
so we're bringing millions of consumers
to interact and transact with sellers
directly with new intermediaries or any
other agent agents in between
the second part of it is the logistics
part of it we're also solving a
logistics problem by
integrating multiple
logistics partners into one single
integrated logistics it used to be
called in my old accenture days as a
popular but what it is is that you're
using technology to integrate different
asset owners and then using jimmy's
technology to also be the you know
manage the data and how they operate so
jamia doesn't own the logistics supply
chain but it has a platform that allows
you to get the right players in there
when you need them where you need them
exactly so it's an asset light model you
have people who have the assets you have
people who have tricycles and vans and
so on but what was lacking
was always the technology to integrate
that together and to use the data to
make you know quality decisions of where
do you deliver what timeline is that you
know required and so on and so forth at
what point does jamia decide we should
build this in-house versus we should
partner in is that conversation ongoing
or maybe that's a trade secret but i'm
just curious to know
you have to be comfortable with
complexity if you're going to work in
africa okay
we love complexity and we we enjoy
taking complexity and making it simple
so like i said earlier the problem is
not assets the problem is not people who
have warehouses and hubs all of that
exists
you have people who have warehouses we
have people who have hubs we have people
who have
10 trucks or some people who have five
tricycles
we have all of those assets that exist
so replicating on the asset side is not
creating value
the real asset that then drives
e-commerce is the engine which is really
the technology okay so how do you know
which day of the week uh you can make
certain deliveries what is the speed of
delivery how should you do your routing
so that you're more fuel efficient you
also reduce distance traveled all of
those are relevant information you
cannot get through just owning the
assets you get that through owning the
technology that puts it all together
and the value is the fact that all those
players
are utilizing your technology so you
have the delivery agents who have your
delivery app on their mobile phone
you've got the third-party logistics
players who are using your hub
management system in their businesses
this philosophy
to connect what already exists rather
than start from scratch extends beyond
logistics
jamia works with third-party companies
to facilitate payments
and since their apps are already
familiar to the customer adoption is
relatively seamless
and what about payments i mean i'm
really curious because i love this
transformation and i want to get back to
the transformation that for the informal
sector that's implied in everything you
just said but what about payments so
payments was another part of it
because um i still remember about 2015
just not too long ago
if a consumer made a purchase on jr and
we relied on just payment through a
debit card or credit card and had to
clear on the back end with a bank
sometimes if there was a return it could
take for two weeks because of course the
you know the banks at the time
e-commerce was not really something that
they were really focused on so we had to
develop our own payment a system again
using the same principle
of integrating different payment methods
that a consumer could have
into a seamless platform that will allow
us to clear whether it was credit card
or debit card or mobile money or bank
transfer whatever payment method that
the consumer had we could also integrate
it on that network so that's the third
component and that's why those are the
three parts of our ecosystem
i want to dig down a little bit more
into the payments piece i'm going
straight into the weeds because that's
where i love to be but
are you using third-party payment
providers i mean there's so many
startups now in this space fintech space
in nigeria there's a lot of venture
capital flowing in i mean i've lost
track of how many of them are are you
doing your own thing or you're working
with all of these third-party providers
we agnostic so we're working with all
all third parties yeah and especially
given how large the market is
the real value you bring to consumers is
not limiting them to your own solution
it's actually giving them a platform
through which they could use whatever
payment methodology that they have
[Music]
e-commerce is relatively new in africa
and platforms like jamia are
transforming the informal market one
example access to information it's huge
i mean because look at the number of
sellers on in africa who are small
medium enterprises in the informal
market and then when they get on to
junior look at the the kinds of
information that is available to them
suddenly they know for example what
which ones of their
items are the fastest moving
which are what price points
which particular color if you're in
fashion if you're fashion seller and
junior you suddenly know whether it's
the blue shirt or the red shirt that
actually sells better than the other
skus that you have
that's very powerful information they
get information in terms of even the
placement of the products the products
information which they put up on site
they get information on their seller
score and all that so really formalizing
informal trade is what it's a huge huge
benefit that an e-commerce platform like
jr is bringing to to the sellers in in
africa so that's a huge part that's a
really big transition from where they
were before
so that i love that that's the data
analytics piece which is for some of
them i think probably data they've never
had or they had intuitively or they had
it on paper and pen
can you tell how many of your sellers
are new sellers i mean in other words
that they would not be in the
marketplace
if it wasn't online oh yes yeah we ran a
survey recently and we have sellers in
between
30 to 40 percent of our sellers who say
look you know they started their
business exclusively on junior right
and some sellers start their businesses
on junior some sellers came to junior to
expand their businesses but what i
actually find extremely interesting is
the number of women sellers that we have
on junior
so we have at least in nigeria and kenya
which are key markets about 51 of our
sellers are actually women
and why do women find it attractive
it's a gender agnostic environment
you could be a fashion seller you could
be an electronic seller and you know you
don't have a it's not a physical market
where someone can make those kinds of
gender related decisions or whether i
want to buy an electronic product from
my from a woman or not so that is giving
them access to different categories that
they could perform in two
it is also
giving women flexibility to be able to
manage their homes and at the same time
run a business of their own the third
component that women say they really
appreciate uh selling on junior it's um
it's the training training on digital
marketing training on how to sell online
training on even how to read your
account statements just those basic
kinds of training the importance for an
sme just cannot be overemphasized
i love that point you know we're always
trying to get more women ceos into our
program
and we do commissioned a study to look
at what are some of the barriers to
entry for women entrepreneurs across the
african continent and you just hit a
bunch of them access to capital like if
you want to open a storefront you're
it's going to be super hard to find that
fifty thousand or hundred thousand
dollar loan the second is access to
networks
women traditionally in not just in
africa but across the world have trouble
accessing networks and then the third is
access to technology and i include
training under technology right that is
the most basic technology
and not getting the same opportunity so
those are really powerful elements of
the platform
[Music]
we've talked in recent weeks about how
technology-based lenders are changing
the landscape for sme finance in africa
jumea has their own credit platform
called jamia lending i wanted to know
how they approach lending differently so
jr lending connects um sellers on our
platform
leveraging their transaction data
transaction history to then find working
capital loans through all the financial
services providers who who who are
partners to jumia so we don't lend off
our balance sheet we do the connection
to financial services providers
it makes total sense to me because in
interviewing a number of fintech ceos
for my podcast
you know they're all using algorithms
and machine learning as alternative
sources of data for assessing credit
worthiness and the number one thing they
use for little like working capital
loans for trading companies and
retailers is what's your repayment
history
and it's not coming from banks because
banks aren't doing 500 loans right so
but the other one would be what's your
revenue history right so if you can show
that from jamia hey i'm this is my
monthly revenue that's hugely valuable
to those fintech algorithms
because that's the data they need
that's interesting
let's talk about kovid for a second how
important was covid in the lockdowns the
determining factor in the growth of
e-commerce is it just a
blip in an otherwise rapidly growing bow
wave or or was it determinative in your
growth
i think it was a blip in africa look at
it in the u.s here the u.s government
more or less bank ruled retail doing
coverage right so put money in people's
accounts and you're sitting at home what
are you gonna do you're gonna you have
to spend the money online right
so the fed bankrolled
retail during the pandemic you don't
have that equivalent in other areas like
africa and in some cases where we had
intermittent lockdowns and movement
restrictions so it wasn't such a big
factor
in terms of
growth of e-commerce rather e-commerce
have had been on a trajectory given the
fact that you have over 500 million
internet users
africa is also a mobile first
environment right so it's almost like
africans have been hungry to do more
with their mobile phones and e-commerce
just happened to be one of those areas
if there's any area where i think there
was a lot more awareness
during covet about the potential of
e-commerce it's in the public policy and
public agency environment where they
suddenly realized that this is something
that can actually be leveraged in a
situation like a pandemic and
and has great potential for jobs and
great potentials for economic
development as well
juliet's transition from ceo to
chairwoman of the jumea group has
necessitated a shift in focus from the
company's present to its future how
jamia will fit in the landscape of
african commerce and how to sustain the
business model long term
that means engaging with the wider
ecosystem including government
in speaking with a lot of tech enabled
companies fintech medtech health tech
the observation is that we recognize
that there is a role for regulation to
protect consumers
the problem is when the regulatory
authorities are not at the cutting edge
of what's happening so the regulations
themselves even if they come from a
place of good intention
they may actually be a hindrance or a
barrier growth and so what's needed is a
dialogue and so my question to you is is
there a group of companies and people
like yourself
who are collaborating to work with
regulators to say let's get this right
together
definitely so just on the on the context
people say that that you know regulators
that they're not on the same plane but
it's our responsibility as private
sector to educate
and a lot of my work in the past year
and so has been that education providing
information to say look this is this is
what we're doing
to a large extent we've actually spent
more time just explaining this is what
we're doing this is this is what a
marketplace model looks like these are
the responsibilities of the platform
versus the seller you know versus the
consumer and all that so i think it's
our responsibility as private sector to
do it and that's what we've been doing
okay in some of our markets also we've
we've formed coalitions with like-minded
private sector companies in nigeria we
have the e-commerce group within the
lagos chamber of commerce i am actually
the
the first chairwoman of of that council
in kenya we have a private sector
alliance
and we have an e-commerce sector within
the alliance so all of those are
opportunities to engage with with
regulators and it's always to the
interest of private sector to engage
early
that way you can provide the necessary
information and education and dialogue
because they want to do the right thing
they just want to be well informed in
taking the right decision sometimes you
provide parallels from other markets you
can show what's going on in the u.s or
china and
you know how the african environment is
different and and you make your your
recommendations and they listen
you are responsible for sustainability
for the group
what does that mean for jamia and what
are some of the key initiatives that
you're focused on of the organization is
focused on in the sustainability space
the first thing for us is actually
very clear validation that our mission
itself
is sustainable we don't have to
invent some new
projects to go after i mean it doesn't
mean of course we would have to operate
in a sustainable manner reducing in
terms of our shipments reducing use of
packaging materials and all that so all
of those are very important hygiene
factors which we build into our
day-to-day operation
but just realizing that our mission
which is about
in the end when you look at is about
reducing inequality
is so critical and is a big part of how
we create value
and how we create sustainable
improvement and quality of lives on the
continent and asking ourselves what what
more can we do
with that mission and second part of it
is
that we have a full ecosystem of many
partners that working together can
actually create more value for the
communities that we live in than just
junior itself we have sellers we have
third-party logistics partners we have
brands who work with us so that's a full
ecosystem that if we deploy can actually
do a lot more for sustainability
so that's our focus and that's our area
of attention for this first year i mean
this is the first year that we're
actually putting together
our practices what we're doing and we
would have a report our first report
next year
a very practical example is how many
sellers on junior
are classified as smes how many sellers
on junior have been able to get access
to working capital loans to grow their
businesses how many sellers on jr women
how many of them have utilized the
training facilities that we provide how
many of them have utilized their loans
to be able to grow their businesses
those are huge huge areas of
sustainability that we we haven't even
scratched all of it right let's let's
utilize what we have
first and then
there are other levers which we can also
concentrate on so those are some
examples for you there
there's a great question here i'm going
to jump in on this one because this is
actually direction i wanted to go
how does jamia evaluate markets for
potential entry
and do you ever decide markets are no
longer viable the person who's asking
this question mentions that jamia pulled
out of cameroon
i want to tack on my own question to
that you mentioned you're in 11
countries 500 million people and
accounting for some enormous percentage
of the total gdp on the continent can
you go to this question and talk a
little bit about the barriers to
regional expansion and what you look for
when you pick a new country to enter
the question i was actually right yeah
we had to pull out of cameroon remember
there was a time when cameroon the
internet was shut down for almost a
whole year okay so these are very
important uh factors that we look at we
look at the
the state of the economy
we look at beyond gdp beyond uh economic
factors we're also looking at readiness
for an internet based business like ours
so those are very important nuances that
we consider in terms of looking at
expansion
for now we're we're deepening our
footprints within the countries that we
are in
maybe in the future but def certainly
for this year we're we're really
concentrating on those 11 countries
where we're currently in
all said and done uh we are the largest
e-commerce platform on the continent but
we also in a continent where
e-commerce and i would say all of modern
trade is probably still within the ranks
of two to five percent of total retail
so you still have a huge upside huge
huge upside so before you stop tinkering
with
other kinds of categories and you know
new verticals and so on just even that
alone is a significant area to to focus
on and that's and that's what our focus
is and i think the other thing we are
focusing on as well is really the shift
that consumers have made
from using e-commerce coming to junior
to buy the electronics they wanted to
buy products of high value because they
could get it at a good price on junior
and they could get
quality assurance and and all of that to
their everyday products
so people want to buy food people want
to buy essential items home cleaning
agents beauty and perfumes consumables
basically that's a huge shift and that's
where we are also deepening our presence
in
i want to go to your the competitive
landscape in a second but i want to
pause and talk about consumables because
i mean one of the things that makes
consumables possible here in the united
states is that you can get it tomorrow
right
you can get your vegetables they're
still fresh they are maybe even cold
packed right you you need a toilet roll
you need cleaning products whatever it
is
is that a big deal is that important to
your consumers that they get something
really fast or not not yet yeah there's
always a trade-off
sometimes it's your
it's the consumer's
living environment that flows into their
expectations okay
so because in the states right next the
corner there's either kroger or there's
a target or there's a wegmans or
any other brand you know that you can
pop into and buy
so that flows into consumer expectations
of you know when do i want it i want it
like in 10 minutes of course you can use
instacart as well and you get the
product very quickly
in our environment is slightly different
consumers are making trade-offs and for
them it probably the pricing is more
important
so i got the perfect question here for
you that just follows on this
as part of your impact goals does jumia
have any
special role in supporting or
facilitating local manufacturing in the
countries where you operate
we work very closely with brands so we
have several brands that are listed on
junior
and
we see an increasing interest from
brands to be on junior for many reasons
one being of course that it gives an
opportunity for them to go direct to the
consumer
through jr as a platform too it gives
them very useful consumer insight
and a lot of that consumer insight is in
terms of packaging in terms of product
specifications
all of that is useful for a manufacturer
in development and product development
and production so the answer is yes
local manufacturers find being on jr
extremely useful for their demand
planning and production
[Music]
let's pivot a little bit to the
competitive landscape who are your
competitors is it kong.com or take a lot
you know other e-commerce companies that
are in the continent or is amazon a
threat from afar
i think when you look at it at the end
of the day competition is is more the
the informal market right because all of
that put together you've just talked
about whether it is conga or piccolo or
any other platform or modern uh brick
and mortar retail and so on and so forth
all of that like i said earlier is just
two to five percent max the real
competition is the info is the informal
market and
we are every day working to bring more
and more sellers to the platform and
bring more brands to the platform
excite more consumers where we're
currently having our black friday
campaign on
it's usually is a very exciting period
for consumers i had no idea that existed
on your platform oh we were the first to
launch it in africa in 2014.
around here that's like that's when i
try to go for a hike in the woods
because it's too mad everywhere else
[Music]
let me ask a bit more about you know
where does jamia look for its its vision
do you look more to the east's you know
chinese e-commerce
like taobao or jd or dojin or do you
look more to western models as you think
through your growth strategy
i would say we're much closer to the
asian alibaba model because we're more
of a marketplace
but then
there are structural differences between
africa and china some of the
infrastructure developments and even
things like you know having a national
postal system and driving down the coast
of postal services some of those things
which uh taobao for example leapfrogged
in developing
uh in china we don't have those in
africa so
we look more at our consumers i would
say in terms of what are the
expectations what are their needs what's
evolving for them in the market what's
critical
brands have begun selling directly
through social media cutting out the
middleman
i asked juliet how social commerce
factors into jamia's future plans
we view social commerce as complementary
to some respects in the sense that
there's a lot of sushi comments on
whatsapp and
instagram but it's also exposed some of
the challenges of social commerce in
terms of protection of consumers
sometimes because you order something it
doesn't get delivered and you don't have
a system whereby you can trust in them
in the returns process you can test them
in quality assurance and and so on
every time we pull our consumers they
tell us that one of the things they
really really love on junior is they
don't want to deal with a seller
they don't care who the seller is okay i
mean that's i'm speaking figuratively
the person they have a relationship with
is junior so if something goes wrong
they want to know that it's junior
they're dealing with we we always talk
about the fact that when you're ordering
online that many things we provide the
item has probably been q seed it's been
you can see the seller score so you can
make decisions between multiple options
which seller to go with payments and all
of that so there's a whole lot that's
riding on just completing a purchase
online that consumers
like the option of having someone the
intermediary the platform that is taking
some of those responsibilities for them
one of the biggest hurdles for any
e-commerce company is building trust
that if i give you my money you'll send
the product
this is especially true in markets where
those online buying habits haven't been
well established
i asked juliet what has jumia done to
create trust with buyers and sellers
for any marketplace of course you would
have issues sometimes with sellers and
so on and so forth but like you
mentioned we do have recourse mechanisms
uh we have penalties we score sellers by
many things by speed of delivery by the
quality of the item by the return rate
of the items that they sell on the
platform so many things are built into
it and of course we have seven items
which must be q seed we have
manufacturer warranties and we offer
everything that you can think of from a
recourse perspective
and for some of our consumers also
depending on the type of item and the
specific consumer's behavior on our
platform sometimes a consumer wants to
return something and we refund
immediately even before the item is
retrieved okay so there many things were
built into
creating an environment that consumers
can trust and feel comfortable to shop
online
we've heard a lot about what jumia has
done to change the commerce paradigm in
africa and as we wrapped up our
conversation i asked juliet how much she
thought e-commerce would actually drive
development across the continent
i mean it's already contributing to
development on the continent there was a
bcg report that talked about the fact
that look you know marketplaces like
jumeirah by 2025 could be
contributing almost 3 million jobs on
the continent so in terms of you're
talking about jobs that's one number two
you and you're talking about formalizing
informal uh retail like you mentioned uh
you're also recognized as another area
which is the cross-border trade within
africa itself so those are many pathways
and many areas in which
e-commerce and companies like junior can
make significant
contribution to the continent
we tend to think of these shifts as
inevitable a byproduct of technological
advances but i think jamia shows how
much careful thought and effort has to
go into solving a host of problems in
traditional largely informal markets
their commitment to using existing
assets and working with partners who are
already on the ground has eased adoption
trust was built with tools for buyer
recourse and access to information for
sellers
and collaborative work with regulators
will help solidify their standing as
they create their own paradigm for
commerce on the continent but jamia is
not alone
although the potential pan-african
market is huge there are many new and
some established players competing
aggressively for it i do wish jamia all
the best as they seek to scale
thanks to juliette anima of the jumea
group and to luke sakhora in the
entrepreneurial thought leader series
for organizing this conversation
if you'd like to check out the full talk
you can go to the stanford ecorner
youtube page or follow the link in our
show notes
[Music]
women in the workplace face unique
challenges and opportunities that's why
i'm excited to introduce two programs
designed for women leaders like you
offered by stanford gsb executive
education and led by maggie neal and
deborah gruenfeld
high potential women leaders is a live
online program
and the executive program in women's
leadership is a one-week on-campus
program
both equip you with the tools and
mindset to fundamentally change the way
you lead
visit
stanfordgsbwomen.com to learn more
i'm also excited to share with you that
season two of the grit and growth
podcast will feature interviews with
both maggie neal and deborah grunfeld
this has been britain growth with
stanford graduate school of business and
i'm your host darius teeter if you like
this episode leave us a review on your
podcast app it really helps us to share
the stories of these incredible
entrepreneurs with as many people as
possible to learn how stanford graduate
school of business is partnering with
entrepreneurs throughout africa and
south asia
head over to the stanford seed website
at seed.stanford.edu
podcast
lori fuller researched and developed
content for this episode with additional
research by jeff prickett kendra gladice
is our production coordinator and our
executive producer is tiffany steves
with writing and production from andrew
gannom and sound design and mixing by
alex bennett at lower street media
thanks for joining us we'll see you next
time
[Music]
you